the Joe Rogan experience he might be you
might be the most powerful man so let me
ask you this what do you think about all
this alien [ __ ] that's going on right
now all this UFO [ __ ] what do you think
that is you think that's a distraction
the stuff that's going on right now the
flies that just got d-class they're
trying that's what it is
the Phi's the d-class are you kidding
that's gonna bury a lot of people go to
jail so you think that's why the UFO
stuff is out there
they've it's always been about UFOs
really since they do that like they have
certain UFO cases that they say listen
if anything gets weird we're just gonna
let this [ __ ] loose woo and
we're gonna tell people listen we've
seen the aliens we've got a hold of them
we've got to alert Congress we got to
talk to people and then people start
just forgetting about corruption
forgetting about the BP oil spill forget
about whatever the [ __ ] is dude the
aliens are coming you trust me yes
they've been talking to the government
you know what my argument against it has
always been why would they talk to the
government if you're from another
[ __ ] planet like wheat when we visit
chimpanzees we don't say hey who's the
number-one chimp we want to bring you
bananas and sign a peace treaty with you
we don't give a [ __ ] who the leader is
yeah you don't get special deals yeah
you don't get special deals oh the top
chimp made a deal to let us kidnap some
baby chimps so we could bring them to
the zoo you know who the [ __ ] out of
here if they're coming here from another
planet they must be so much more
sophisticated than we are they're not
going to listen us we're crazy they're
doing it for several reasons in my
opinion and and one like exactly like
you said when there's four distractions
and right now they're going heavy with
it but you know Wernher von Braun the
last four years of his life he had
cancer and he had an assistant and we
watch it on YouTube talk her name is dr.
Carol Rosalyn and she said that he kept
telling her over and over cuz they're
preparing like on his deathbed they're
preparing for a fake alien invasion
that's what they're trying to scare us
into a new world order
and she talked about this huh no no she
doesn't say why he goes he never told me
why he just kept telling me there all
this stuff you hear about aliens and
asteroids it's all fake first there's
gonna be a environmental threat that
they're gonna scare everybody with
global warming is my opinion in my
opinion then there's gonna be asteroid
threats and then the final one and she
says this and he kept saying this is the
final one the last one they're gonna do
is the fake alien invasion that's gonna
that's why there's movies like
Independence Day it gets everyone used
to oh we're all good let's call China
and Russia and we all band together and
good call it's it's to get us prepared
for a new one-world government that's
what it's really all about the aliens
and all that the Nazis were doing that
to their own people they made in the
when I was balls-deep in the UFO
community we would you know they would
they would show us that you know there's
pictures of the German UFOs and in the
UFO community we looked at that is
evidence that they must have found
crashed UFOs and then they're trying to
reverse engineer that's what everybody
in the UFO community thinks but when you
look into it
dude they were trying to scare their own
people to look for the government
they're just science fiction had flying
saucers before flying saucers were
something that the government or the
Germany you look at the time they tried
to create so yeah I think they were
trying to freak people out and make it
seem like it was aliens yes exactly so
so World War two is over we didn't have
Operation Paperclip look Operation
Paperclip from 1945 1946 we bring in
over all right the guys that ended up
creating the CIA and NASA were from
Operation Paperclip
so right away short NASA so when you
look at this if the Nazis were trying to
scare their own people with fake UFOs
they must have came in and said dude you
guys aren't on the UFO [ __ ] you got to
scare your people so that's exactly when
all the comic books were all these so
the Germans were scaring their people
with UFOs before the United States comes
really yes this is the 30s that is
listen if you're gonna be a master of
propaganda like Hitler was right yes
manipulation and propaganda
who wanted an order more than hurt them
who wanted to control the world more
than that guy that guy knew how to do it
and and it's an old idea it's an old
idea or way everybody the old the
ancient Roman emperors they all want
they'll jump for that one world
government they couldn't pull it off
there was no way they could pull it off
because the only way to make a new world
order actually happen is you got to get
the people to embrace it you can't force
them into it so you got a mind [ __ ] them
to embrace a new world order you got to
make them want it otherwise they're not
going to stay in their own little truck
exactly all the little rulers were go
like did we do one world government I'm
out of a job [ __ ] you so it's impossible
but they knew they theorized if there
was some kind of alien threat they don't
remember Reagan talking about exactly
when you're in the UFO community
you take that Reagan speech from the UN
and from the CFR and you look at that as
proof that there's aliens but now I look
at that when you look at him and I get
the CFR he goes wouldn't all our jobs be
a little bit easier if there was some
sort of threat some extraterrestrial
threat he's Don says the rule he's well
it's not exactly I'm talking about he
did a many to different suit he was
doing it all no that was a bunch of them
yeah he was on a mission to get everyone
and like but he's like making it sound
like humanitarian like wouldn't wouldn't
we'll all her differences just see her
diminish if there was some sort of
extraterrestrial threat that was getting
everybody used to this [ __ ] we're gonna
come the UN is all my running off they
they can't do it but now we're
approaching the tech we have the
technology now with Holograms now we
could do it it's always been for
hundreds of years they knew that they
knew that but they couldn't pull it off
how you gonna pull it off how he's gonna
do to know how to make that [ __ ] or
making movies when you imagine what do
you saying I told you about this last
week you said you didn't see it was
talking about the military-industrial
complex forcing the president right is
he talking about space force now you can
reassure people you're not looking fo
this is Fox News man you can't play this
it's the news yeah it's Fox it's like a
clip from a fox in a news it's the news
though yeah but I think you get pulled
for them you don't meet a plan
play it but if the news would always
play them okay let me know what saying
let me hear him say this is my friend
Steve Hilton show and don't kid yourself
you do have a military-industrial
complex they do like war you know in
Syria with the caliphate so I wipe out a
hundred percent of the Caliphate that
doesn't mean you're not going to have
these crazy people going around blowing
up stores and blowing up things these
are seriously ill people I don't want to
say oh they're wiped you know Isis but I
wiped out a hundred percent of the
Caliphate I say I want to bring our
troops back home the place went crazy
they want to keep that you have people
here in why she wanted they never want
to leave I say you know what I'll do
I'll leave a couple hundred soldiers
behind but if it was up to them they'd
bring thousands of soldiers in someday
people will explain what this is if you
do have you whoa yeah that's [ __ ]
heavy I'll stop right here
now if that was from anyone in any
normal person you would say that guy's
out of his [ __ ] mind that's a
conspiracy there's no one who wants war
but you hear that from the actual
sitting president of the United States
there was no reason to say that like why
is he why does he ever reason say that
it must be an excuse for why he didn't
pull everyone out 100% and that's an
that's a really overlooked insight and
that's part of the problem is that so
many people hate Trump that even when he
says something like that that we should
listen to because it's coming from the
president of the United States while
he's a sitting president and why he's
talking about pulling people out of
troop out of war and people still don't
want to listen because it's on Fox News
and because it's the president because
people so many people hate the president
they don't want to hear about this that
should be something that's talked about
the the D class is about to happen [ __ ]
there you think so the well it is a D
class that's about to happen
it's you know what does that mean I mean
these declassification of FISA
applications at the class everything
involved in how the Russian
investigation started yeah that's the
problem
they were trying to there's evidence and
that this is coming with the FISA D
class that Trump wasn't supposed to win
the
text messages going back between two FBI
agents right sorry well would if he wins
and goes he won't get aware he's gonna
Hillary's gonna crush him like a zillion
to one and this but what if he does win
these are text message have been
released